we launched with product and Market in
January of 2020.
we had imagined doing events and
concerts and selling in restaurants all
of that disappeared overnight we found
ourselves with about 40 000 cans of wine
and no way to get them out there
my background is actually not in wine I
was previously in healthcare and
Consulting I worked in corporate
strategy and corporate development I
worked in marketing in San Francisco I
did get burnt out in technology and
wanted to do something different
while at Stanford I met my now
co-founder and best friend Sarah I had
asked her to be my partner for this
class startup garage to explore the
canned wine idea because she was the
smartest person that I knew we spent six
months meeting with wineries ideating on
our concept and our business model what
this allowed us to do was pressure test
our ideas and start to build up a
network and whine in the startup
ecosystem it was roughly six months
later when we were first connected to
now our third co-founder Zoe through the
GSB Network I was introduced to Sarah
and Kendra as soon as we started working
together we knew that Zoe needed to be a
part of our team now the three of us
really are inseparable
makerwine is a new kind of wine company
we partner with small independent
Wineries and we can their Flagship wines
[Music]
we started maker to create a new kind of
company that shined a light on small
independent wineries they are farmers
and artists and scientists not marketers
and sales people or Distributors we're
working very hard to keep the little
guys alive so that we always get to
experience this amazing craft and then
we started to think about what type of
experience was missing as Millennial
wine lovers and wine consumers ourselves
and that's when we really had the aha
moment with cans
foreign
always been in these super stuffy and
approachable heavy glass bottles super
old school outdated the label tells you
nothing not technology forward you never
know if the price is indicative of the
quality
I have a passion and background in the
craft beer industry and saw Cans really
take over that industry because of the
sustainability benefits a lot of people
don't know that glass is actually very
hard to recycle it's recycled in just
about 40 percent of recycling facilities
across the United States the aluminum
format also weighs much less than a
bottle of wine so if you think about the
carbon emissions transporting wine
across the world much better for the
environment there all of those reasons
really got us excited about cans we
actually canned our first three wines
less than two months after graduation
it was a wild time to launch a company
we really had to get creative in how we
launched a new type of wine product
during a global pandemic and candidly
the GSB in Greater Stanford Community
was a huge part of what helped us make
that happen what we started doing was
hosting virtual wine tastings
and we did more than 150 in our launch
here and so it was really leaning on the
network that helped ultimately you know
get us off the ground during a really
tough time
[Music]
Stanford GSB definitely changed my life
I would not be here today as a CEO of
maker if I hadn't gone to the GSB and
met my co-founders and met the people
who backed our business from the very
beginning I don't know that I would have
started this business without the
confidence that the GSB gave me you walk
out of there and you feel like you can
do anything I chose the GSB because I
wanted to be in a community of people
with not only business smarts but that
were really conscientious humans
everyone that I met that went to GSB was
passionate excited doing something
really unique I wanted to be around
those people and be inspired to build
something great too
the motto of the GSB is changing lives
changing organizations change the world
on the whole why we are building maker
why we consider ourselves a
mission-driven wine company is so that
we can make wine better I really want
maker to be this incredible platform for
these Independent Producers to get to
highlight you know minority and
women-owned Wineries and make those
stories more visible I think has had an
impact when we are successful wine as an
industry really should put the human at
the center
foreign
[Music]